monte carlo simulation is a mathematical
technique which is used to estimate the
possible outcomes of an uncertain event
it's a chance to see into the future and
while actual time travel is still beyond
us let's address three questions about
monte carlo simulations to get you on
your way to making better decisions
come on in guys so number one
how do they work
multi-color simulation works by modeling
the probability of different outcomes in
a process or a system that cannot easily
be predicted due to the intervention of
random variables and it uses something
called random
sampling
and rambling random sampling is used to
generate multiple possible outcomes and
calculate the average result
so take for example the calculation of
the probability
of rolling two standard dice
well if you wanted to calculate this
probability the brute force way you
would have to roll the dice a whole
bunch say
36
000 times if we consider that there are
six sides to a dice we have two of them
and we want to run this a thousand times
to get a good sample size but with a
monte carlo simulation we can reduce the
number of roles by randomly sampling the
possible outcomes knowing there are 36
combination of dice rolls and
calculating the percentage of times that
we get say a seven
now number two
who uses them there are a number of
common applications for monte carlo
simulations and perhaps the most well
known of those is in the area
of just portfolio management
and also in the area of investment
planning
by running thousands or even millions of
simulations investors can get a better
idea of how their portfolio might
perform under different market
conditions and other common applications
are things like risk analysis option
pricing and planning for spare capacity
but a monte carlo simulation is applied
in all sorts of fields from medicine all
the way through to astrophysics all the
way through to figuring out
what today's
wordle might actually be
okay number three how
to run one
monte carlo techniques involve three
basic steps
first you set up the
predictive
model
and this is identifying both the
dependent variable to be predicted and
the independent variables also known as
the input risk of predictive variables
that will drive the predictions
secondly you specify the probability
distribution
and that's the probability distribution
of the independent variables you can use
historical data or an analyst's
subjective judgment to define a range of
likely values and assign probability
weights for each
and then number three
we can run
simulations repeatedly generating random
values of the independent variables
do this until enough results are
gathered to make up a representative
sample of the near infinite number of
possible combinations
you can run as many monte carlo
simulations as you wish by modifying the
underlying parameters you use to
simulate the data however you'll also
want to compute the range of variation
within a sample by calculating the
variance and the standard deviation
which are commonly used measures of
spread
the more you sample the more accurate
your sampling range and then the better
your estimation
and while you may not be able to travel
into the future with monte carlo
simulation you'll have a much better
idea about the possibilities
that the future holds
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe thanks for watching